my name is Ben I'm 19 I have about
$10,000 in Investments and about $5,000
in cash and I am debt free I just
recently got my uh first credit card and
I'm having a really hard time going
against my saving Instinct uh it was
just something my parents kind of
pressured me into getting and I just am
having a really hard time understanding
why I need this un tangible thing called
credit Ben you are speaking my language
how do I overcome this okay so the truth
is and uh your parents are very
well-meaning and they love you but they
fell for the Trap and here's the Trap
telling your kid they have to get a
credit card and why did they tell you to
get a card
Ben uh to build up credit boom to get
your credit score up and why do you need
a high credit
score to pay for a house to get loans to
get
loans